bonjour Yannick Jadot bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité vous êtes
débutant en Europe Écologie Les Verts
anciens candidat à la présidentielle et
futur candidat au sénatorial merci
d'être on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
westfrance bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour on va évidemment parler de
l'actualité des sénatoriales de la
réforme des retraites mais on a appris
il y a quelques instants ce qui s'est
passé en Ukraine Yannick Jadot et la
Russie qui aurait fait sauter un barrage
hydroélectrique du côté de Kerson veut
le des meilleurs élanski en tout cas Kef
dénonce un crime de guerre est-ce que
c'est aussi ce que vous dites écoutez il
faut attendre on a effectivement cette
cette information
c'est potentiellement dramatique c'est
une centrale de hydroélectrique donc
c'est la fourniture d'électricité c'est
potentiellement un drame écologique
c'est aussi d'après ce qu'on comprend
une infrastructure qui permet de
refroidissement de la centrale nucléaire
deux aborigia on sait à quel point elle
est en permanence menacée
donc on attend mais effectivement dans
cette guerre les crimes sont commis par
l'armée russe qui
ne résiste à aucune
j'allais dire
valeur morale éthique on connaît les
crimes de guerre et ses potentiellement
un autre crime de guerre est-ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin aujourd'hui dans
l'aide à l'Ukraine pour l'aider à mener
sa contre-offensive je pense qu'on fait
ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui on sait la
difficulté notamment en matière de
munition c'est un des enjeux
les chats arrivent en Ukraine c'est une
bonne chose vous savez que les
écologistes dans cette guerre n'ont
jamais hésité dès le premier jour nous
soutenons la résistance ukrainienne nous
soutenons sur le continent européen tous
les efforts pour que l'invasion russe
soit stoppée que la Russie quitte
l'Ukraine et puis évidemment que les
crimes contre l'humanité qui ont été les
crimes de guerre soit évidemment
mis devant la justice que les
responsables de ces crimes soient mis
devant la justice y compris Vladimir
Poutine l'actualité aujourd'hui c'est
cette nouvelle journée de mobilisation
14e journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites alors que le
décret portant la retraite à 64 ans est
paru ce week-end au Journal officiel
est-ce que la bataille politique est
perdue pour non elle n'est pas perdue je
pense qu'elle est d'abord perdue pour la
France puisque
c'est une c'est une terrible histoire de
la démocratie française ça fait cinq
mois six mois qu'une réforme portée par
le seul président de la République et
son gouvernement rejetés par les
Français très majoritairement rejeté
qu'à la quasi unanimité des salariés qui
n'aura finalement peut-être jamais été
voté jamais été voté par l'Assemblée
nationale peut se mettre en place le
président de la République a usé de tous
les contournement de l'esprit de la
Constitution à écraser la démocratie
sociale veut continuer à écraser la
démocratie parlementaire moi j'ai un
appel ce matin à la Présidence de
l'Assemblée à la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce qu'elle
veut marquer l'histoire en défendant le
Parlement en défendant la démocratie
parlementaire ou est-ce qu'elle
participera à écraser le Parlement quel
président c'est la question qui est la
sienne aujourd'hui pour vous brandir
l'article 40 de la part de Philippe ce
serait écrasé le Parlement bien sûr vous
rendez compte que on est quand même ce
sujet cette réforme a été au cœur de
l'actualité politique depuis six mois
depuis 6 mois vous avez les Français qui
s'y opposent qui
manifeste qui se mobilise avec des
manifestations énormes et soutenu pas
simplement énorme dans la rue et exemple
dans le soutien de l'opinion publique
cette loi encore une fois les 64 ans
jusqu'à maintenant n'ont jamais été voté
à l'assemblée il n'y a pas eu de vote
sur les 64 ans il y a l'opportunité d'un
vote ça s'appelle la démocratie
de la gauche a fait durer les débats
écoutez moi je regrette qu'effectivement
à ce moment-là
l'article 7 n'est pas été voté mais la
réalité c'est qu'il y a jamais eu de
vote et qu'aujourd'hui c'est une
obstruction du gouvernement c'est une
obstruction de la majorité qui empêche
en fait l'Assemblée du peuple de
s'exprimer c'est absolument dramatique
et là on voit si vous voulez on a quand
même un président de la République qui
en 2017
a été élu sur une forme de renouveau
démocratique de renouveau de la méthode
pour présider ce pays beaucoup pensez
voter pour retard ou Mendes France en
disant ça va être de nouveau compromis
on casse un peu les systèmes politiques
conservateurs non seulement le président
de la République a cassé les partis
politiques mais il est en train d'abîmer
nos institutions il est en train
d'abîmer la démocratie
peut-être certains pensaient lire au car
on Mendès France ils ont élu Giscard
pour l'arrogance et Sarkozy pour la
brutalité vous êtes vous êtes raccord
avec avec le propos de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon dans l'entretien qui va donner
à 20 minutes dimanche Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui est avec Monsieur Macron nous ne
sommes plus vraiment République c'est
certain mais nous sommes aussi en train
de sortir du cadre de la démocratie vous
faites ces propos vôtres j'ai dit
il y a déjà plusieurs plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois que le Président de la
République était dans une dérive libéral
alors attention je dis pas qu'on est en
Pologne et qu'on est en gris mais quand
à un moment donné vous écrasez la
démocratie parlementaire et la
démocratie sociale quand vous
considérez que un mouvement social
devient la foule que les manifestants
deviennent des factions quand vous
commencez à contester ce qu'a fait ce
gouvernement le corps donc le le
l'organisme
plus à plusieurs acteurs qui définit la
trajectoire sur le système des retraits
que vous contestez lances sur la santé
l'environnement que vous contestez la
LDH et les contre-pouvoirs que les
écologistes dans le premier quinquennat
c'était les Amish dans le deuxième
quinquennat sont les écho terroristes
que vous criminalisez les sauts d'action
à l'expression
et d'expression qui renforcent
l'autoritar qui consiste à disqualifier
en permanence et à combattre les
contre-pouvoirs ça s'appelle une dérive
libérale et donc c'est extrêmement
dangereux pour la démocratie surtout
qu'à la fin quand vous allez au bout de
libéralisme c'est l'extrême droite juste
pour sur la réforme des retraites telles
que vous l'avez évoqué six mois six mois
de lutte dans la rue ou près de
l'opinion de mobilisation très forte là
on a l'impression pour cette 14e journée
ce sera un peu la dernière et qui a une
mobilisation annoncée plutôt faible
est-ce que ce qu'on n'est pas dans un
est-ce que les Français ont pas déjà
tourné la page je crois pas quand on
regarde les enquêtes d'opinion leur
niveau d'opposition à cette réforme est
toujours aussi importante moi je
souhaite qu'il y ait du monde dans la
rue cet après-midi ce sera le cas pour
marquer écoutez on verra je peux pas
j'ai pas une j'ai pas de boule de
cristal évidemment il y a une forme de
lassitude y compris par rapport au coût
que porte le président de la République
et son gouvernement contre la démocratie
il y a une forme de de pas de
résignation parce qu'il y a plutôt
beaucoup de colère
et pas de la résignation mais il y a un
sentiment qu'au fond rien ce président
et ce gouvernement n'entendent de rien
de du rejet de l'opinion publique de la
volonté d'apaiser le pays par les
Françaises et les Français d'avoir un
peu plus de justice sociale de s'occuper
enfin de ce qui les concerne le climat
voilà la dégradation absolue de notre
situation climatique la sécheresse on
est au début juin il a pas plu depuis je
sais pas combien de temps il fait très
chaud
regardez encore ce qu'il est sorti hier
du de la grande concertation qui a été
mise en place sur le logement
souvenez-vous
la grande concertation avec tous les
acteurs sur les banlieues vous souvenez
le rapport Borlo
Jean-Louis Borloo humilié devant les
Françaises et les Français le rapport
qui avait été mis des mois à sortir par
tous les acteurs mis à la poubelle on a
eu la convention citoyenne sur le climat
des citoyens choisis qui s'emparent du
climat qui font des propositions à la
poubelle et là on a tous les acteurs du
logement depuis la Fédération française
du bâtiment jusqu'à la Fondation Abbé
Pierre en passant par le logement social
les promoteurs les architectes et tout
le monde se sent humilié humilié c'est
que vous pouvez pas abîmer à ce point la
démocratie et tous les processus de
concertation et d'intelligence
collective à chaque fois en disant ah
c'est génial on va vous réunir et en
fait on détruit l'intelligence
collective et la mobilisation des forces
vives de ce pays ça va mal tourner ça va
mal tourner ça veut dire ça va vous dire
à quoi est-ce qu'il y aura un avant et
un après cette séquence réforme des
retraites est-ce que par exemple le
parlementaires écologiste continueront à
sier comme avant
où est-ce qu'il y aura des nouveaux
moyens d'agir
les parlementaires écologistes ils vont
continuer à porter des propositions
encore une fois sur l'eau on voit le
enfin on a tous les scientifiques je me
permets de contourner un peu votre
question pardonnez-moi mais qui sont
extrêmement inquiets aujourd'hui les
forêts en France et dans le monde
absorbe beaucoup moins les océans
absorbent beaucoup moins de CO2
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire que quand on
dit que ça absorbe beaucoup moins ça
veut dire qu'en fait il va y avoir un
dérèglement climatique qui va
s'accélérer encore plus encore plus vite
encore plus fort encore plus durement et
vous avez un gouvernement qui sur le
climat
sur les renouvelables sur la rénovation
thermique des logements sur l'eau sur le
changement de modèle agricole sur la
pollution de l'air veut rien faire il
renonce
hier sur le logement c'est on fera pas
plus sur la rénovation thermique même
Pisani ferries et
Madame mafouze on dit il faut mettre 14
milliards c'est ce qu'on a toujours dit
ils le font pas sur l'eau la France
condamnée mise en demeure montrée du
doigt par la Commission européenne mais
non quand vous avez le plan où on dit
alors il y a un éléphant dans la pièce
ça s'appelle l'agriculture là il s'est
80% de la consommation d'eau l'été 80%
donc l'éléphant il touche les murs de
partout avant on l'a pas vu on l'a pas
vu on fait rien on va continuer à
financer les méga bassines on va tirer
de l'eau qui n'est plus disponible pour
finir pour pour irriguer une agriculture
qui est totalement inadaptée à ces il y
a plus d'eau donc rien ne va et
qu'est-ce que ce cette inaction
permanente c'est renonce moi la justice
sociale comme à la justice fiscale ça
crée une un désespoir dans notre pays et
que nous les forces de progrès les
écologistes on doit réussir à
remobiliser effectivement
on y arrive il faut qu'on y arrive là on
est un peu alors il y a plus d'eau mais
reconnaissons que depuis un an on prend
la vague des réformes antisociales de ce
gouvernement de l'inaction climatique
d'une colère qui monte dans le pays et
nous avons la responsabilité
effectivement de construire le projet
qu'il est convaincra pas simplement
d'être contre et de faire de voir
l'impasse du libéralisme et le danger de
l'extrême droite mais un projet
enthousiasmant qui fait de ces grands
défis un sujet de mobilisation et de
de reconquête de notre de notre pouvoir
de vivre Yann va ça va pas assez vite
pas assez fort il faut il faut tout
changer ça tombe bien il y a des
élections qui arrivent il faut prendre
le pouvoir les prochaines c'est les
sénatoriales vous êtes candidats
qu'est-ce que vous quels sont vos quels
sont vos objectifs par rapport à ces
élections qu'est-ce que vous pensez
pouvoir y faire et apporter aussi
renforcer le groupe écologiste ce Sénat
c'est un groupe qui travaille beaucoup
tous sénateurs aujourd'hui 12 sénateurs
donc l'objectif c'est de se rapprocher
des 20 sénatrices sénateurs d'avoir
dans une dans une assemblée des
territoires qui qui pèse et d'ailleurs
on voit à quel point le gouvernement
bloqué à l'Assemblée passe par le Sénat
aujourd'hui pour construire ces
alliances avec les républicains et ben
il faut y être présent il faut porter
nos idées il faut arracher des victoires
comme ça a été le cas sur
l'avortement c'est quand même très
ambitieux pour ces pour ces le corps
électoral vous est pas forcément très
favorable
c'est on s'est renforcé sur tous les
territoires c'est quand même aussi la
bonne nouvelle c'est des écologistes par
moitié la moitié sur laquelle on va
voter par la plus favorable aux
écologistes écoutez on va voir à Paris
on a eu plus de de sénateurs sénatrice
vous le savez donc on espère de la
gauche ou à votre côté là on a encore
quelques jours pour discuter on discute
avec eux on discute avec l'ensemble des
forces politiques installées sur le
territoire parisien sur le département
mais c'est aussi une négociation
nationale
écoutez on discute on va voir ce qui
s'est vous savez qu'il y a une liste qui
s'est engagée autour de de
la majorité parisienne ce qui est pas
forcément la majorité au sein du Parti
socialiste mais c'est pas mon affaire de
de rentrer dans leur débat interne mais
nous ce qu'on veut discutez avec lui
pourquoi on veut être fort au Sénat je
comédie il y a un dérèglement climatique
il y a la dégradation de la nature de la
biodiversité et ce gouvernement ironce
c'est quand même le terme ça restera la
phrase de de ce quinquennat sur
l'environnement le président de la
République qui appelle finalement une
pause environnementale c'est ça c'est
pas là comme ça qui l'a dit mais c'est
comme ça qu'il a voulu le faire
comprendre comme ça cosy l'avait fait en
disant l'environnement ça commence à
suffire
sur les nouvelles normes européennes pas
créer de nouvelles normes au fond il se
rapproche de la droite européenne qui
aujourd'hui dit pouf ça cogne tellement
sur l'environnement la catastrophe qu'on
n'a pas anticipé sur laquelle on n'a pas
agi est tellement là que finalement le
meilleur moyen de régler le problème
dans l'environnement c'est de plus en
parler et de plus agir on va mettre ça
de côté
donc au fond c'est je sais pas quoi
c'est une sorte d'anxiolytique où on se
dit finalement ne plus en parler c'est
ne plus avoir de crise mais non elle est
là et c'est totalement irresponsable et
le président de la République s'inscrit
et donc nous écologistes on veut porter
ça au Sénat vous savez combien nous
sommes des fédéralistes donc s'il y
avait des réformes qui permettaient de
renforcer le pouvoir des régions des
collectivités c'est un sujet très
important pour nous c'est le sujet de
Paris confronté au dérèglement
climatique comme à la question du
logement comme à la question du
transport et puis nous voulons porter la
question de la proportionnelle enfin
tout ce bazar dont on parle c'est
incapacité
au Parlement que ce soit l'assemblée au
Sénat d'intervenir correctement dans le
débat public le le
la façon dont les institutions ne
fonctionnent plus la démocratie de
fonctionne plus la façon dont
emmanuellement comme Macron concentre
les pouvoirs et puis tous les débats de
la nupesse sur comment se débrouille en
2027 on va reconnaissons que s'il y
avait la proportionnelle dans notre pays
si on devenait une démocratie mature et
bien
notre pays notre démocratie s'en
trouverait apaisé donc nous avons besoin
de la proportionnelle dans notre pays
d'abord pour 2027 bien sûr donc vous
travaillez une liste d'union de la
gauche c'est pas acté qui aura une liste
écolo à Paris
d'avoir des élus seuls c'est ouvert nous
sommes dans des discussions le le il
reste encore quelques jours pour le vote
le 9 au Conseil de Paris et puis jusqu'à
jusqu'à fin septembre si toutefois vous
partez sur une liste écologiste seul
vous êtes nul vous seriez numéro 2 de la
liste vous êtes Mendès est-ce que vous
êtes sûr d'être élu vous êtes sûr
qu'aucune voix de votre camp ne manquera
il y aura pas de division interne
c'est une campagne électorale on y
travaille très sérieusement vous savez
qu'on a eu un processus de consultation
interne puis il y a eu nos instances
moi j'appelle la responsabilité
j'appelle au respect des votes des
militants au respect de c'est important
d'avoir notamment plus de sénatrice avec
notre groupe on est très très attaché à
la parité au Sénat c'est pas la
c'est pas exactement ce qu'on espérait
donc on va mettre le maximum de
sénatrice en position éligible
vous voyez président du groupe
écologiste
il faut respecter celles et ceux qui
sont là qui connaissent l'institution
qui travaillent donc il y a de de des
personnes très compétentes déjà engagées
depuis un moment au Sénat qui à mon avis
relèveront ce défi du coup vous ne serez
pas candidats européennes
on peut pas tout faire qui
souhaitez-vous voir de succéder comme
tête de liste
il y a une candidate potentielle et un
candidat potentiel
Marie Toussaint David Corman les deux
ont des qualités les deux ne se sont pas
encore positionnés comme candidate ou
candidat tête de liste écoutez on va
voir ce qu'ils vont faire mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que aucun des deux n'avait
de préférence vous avez un choix les
deux les deux les deux ont des ont du
talent ils font un boulot remarquable au
Parlement européen et puis moi je
souhaite ça vous a pas échappé que cette
élection européenne soit une élection
européenne c'est pas un scrutin
intermédiaire c'est pas un sondage
national pour l'élection présidentielle
qui est essentiel ce qui est essentiel
c'est qu'on est beaucoup d'élus
pro-européens au Parlement à Strasbourg
vous savez on a voté sur le devoir de
vigilance la semaine dernière ça s'est
joué à quelques voies et ben ça ça sert
le Parlement européen vous savez la
planification psychologique la seule qui
existe vraiment elle est européenne donc
Mélenchon pour vous les députés à les
filles sont pas suffisamment pour
européens c'est je vous ai dit que
j'étais pour la proportionnelle on a un
scrutin proportionnel à un tour ça
permet aux insoumis d'aller chercher
tous leurs électrices et leurs électeurs
autour de leur projet qui est pas le
nôtre qui est moins pro-européen parfois
plus ambigüe sur la Russie sur la Chine
peu importe je conteste pas leurs
projets c'est le leur mais qu'ils
aillent chercher le maximum d'électeurs
sur leurs projets qu'on aille chercher
le maximum d'électeurs sur notre projet
pour que insoumis et le maximum de
députés les écologistes les socialistes
le maximum de députés et comme nous
travaillons ensemble à l'assemblée de
Strasbourg et ben ça nous permet d'être
plus fort dans les débats c'est chacun
va chercher son électeur pas donc il est
clairement pour vous il est pas question
d'avoir une liste commune européenne le
débat il est Claude tranché ça sert à
rien de revenir et je comprends pas
d'ailleurs
la façon dont Jean-Luc Mélenchon remet
la pression qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire
20 minutes mais qu'est-ce qu'il veut
une liste il sait qu'au fond et c'est
normal c'est le jeu démocratique il y a
pas dramatiser l'élection européenne qui
est inscrita proportionnelle un tour
donc au fond qu'est-ce qui cherche en
disant s'il y a pas de liste commune il
y a plus de nupaises qu'est-ce qui
cherche pour vous mais je vous demande
s'il veut continuer la naine UPS c'est
son c'est son c'est sa réussite la
nupesse pour le scrutin législatif de
2022 il a pris cette initiative et ça a
été une très bonne stratégie de défense
et aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'au
fond si tout le monde n'est pas le doigt
sur la couture de sa stratégie il y a
plus de nups il veut casser le jouet et
ben je trouve que nous avons la
responsabilité à la fois d'utiliser le
scrutin européen pour avoir le maximum
d'élus la proportionnelle un tour chacun
y va avec son projet comme nous avons la
responsabilité de travailler à l'Union
dans notre pays pour faire en sorte
qu'en 2027 passe simplement nous soyons
second tour ça ça serait presque
j'allais dire si on se met ensemble
c'est presque acquis pas sûr mais c'est
acquis si on se met une seule
candidature pour être au second tour
mais la question c'est de gagner
l'élection présidentielle sinon se
trompe de débat mais vous mettez ainsi
ça veut dire que c'est pas acquis pour
vous qui est qu'une seule candidature
est-ce que vous souhaitez comme vous
l'avez été vous qui est un candidat
écologiste en 2027 vous savez un an
avant la présidentielle j'étais le seul
j'ai rassemblé et j'ai voulu rassembler
tous les candidats de gauche écologistes
pour qu'on ait un programme ensemble qui
débouche sur une candidature comme
commune reconnaissons que ni Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ni Fabien Roussel nian Hidalgo
ne voulait cette candidature commune
donc nous avons acté qu'il n'y avait pas
de candidature commune pour 2022 moi je
souhaite qu'il y ait une candidature
commune pour 2027 qui soit écologiste et
de gauche et qui nous permettent encore
une fois pas simplement de se faire
plaisir en allant au second tour mais de
prendre la responsabilité se donner les
moyens de gagner l'élection
présidentielle donc faut faire 50% plus
une voix au second tour
il faut toute la gauche et les
écologistes moi je ne m'inscris pas dans
les gauchers réconciliables j'entends
les uns et les autres dire certains
là j'allais dire je sais pas une partie
du Parti socialiste et devenu un
fréquentable et d'autres de dire les
insoumis sont infréquentables on aura
besoin de tout le monde pour gagner ce
candidat du nom de la gauche et des
écologistes pour 2027 il pourrait
s'appeler Yannick Jadot oh là là moi je
suis candidat à l'élection sénatoriale
si on peut faire les étapes
après les oreillers vous auriez envie
d'y retourner c'est vraiment pas le
sujet franchement c'est pas le sujet
mais non mais enfin je te jure on verra
vous savez c'est on est dans un autre
dans un autre épée espace-temps là moi
je souhaite m'impliquer pleinement dans
la politique nationale parce que je
pense que le risque aujourd'hui très
lourd d'une victoire de Marine Le Pen
avec un Premier ministre qui s'appelle
Wauquiez est très fort regardez ce qui
s'est passé en Espagne pourrait devenir
Premier ministre de marine bien sûr je
vais dire mais regardez c'est ce qui se
passe dans toute l'Europe le le LR a
totalement dérivé vers l'extrême droite
il y a qu'à les écouter sur
l'immigration franchement c'est devenu
totalement lunaire oui quand vous en
êtes quasiment à
hésiter sur le droit du sol le droit du
sang quand vous faites des des immigrés
les boucs émissaires de toutes les
difficultés de la France quand vous
focalisez là-dessus quand vous êtes dans
aussi dans une dérive libérale vous
contestez tous les contre-pouvoirs de la
République et des institutions c'est
totalement fou c'est Orban c'est le pis
en Pologne donc au fond quand vous avez
cette menace là quand vous avez la
société française qui comme beaucoup de
sociétés dans le monde sont prises de
vertige vous avez tendance à
penser plutôt avec les tripes qu'à
regarder devant donc ce risque existe
regarder en pourtant Pedro Sanchez il
gouverne pas mal
économiquement socialement
environnementalement il fait des choses
il va potentiellement être emporté par
la vague populiste de l'alliance de la
droite et de l'extrême droite donc on a
notre nous une responsabilité majeure
que ça n'arrive pas en France et pour ça
y compris à gauche avec les écologistes
faut et c'est pas les écologistes qui
sont avant faut arrêter les détestations
personnelles les zucas sur cette partie
de la gauche c'est un fréquentable les
gauches sont tirées conciliables les
nostalgies régressives parce que
l'élection de 2027 c'est pas réélire
François Mitterrand 81 on peut pas juste
fonctionner sur ce qui nous fait du bien
mais ce qui nous permet pas d'affronter
l'enjeu du climat de la justice sociale
de la justice fiscale et de la
démocratie dans notre pays merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin on regarde la ligne de
Ouest-France un plan pour le logement
qui a du mal à convaincre c'est à la Une
de votre journal Stéphane merci Yannick
Jadot d'avoir été avec nous et peut-être
à bientôt au Sénat avec plaisir merci
beaucoup on passe au club des
territoires